what are they called you know do they
call you my kids all call me dad do they
yeah Jenner gets candid about her
relationship with her children
Kendall ask me a question first and I
know dad I mean I'm your dad and I've
always be your dad till the day I died
in an episode of the UK reality show I'm
a celebrity get me out of here Jenner
shared that she still feels like a
father to her kids more than four years
after coming out as a trans woman
primarily Bruce raised them and kind of
Caitlyn is enjoying their life for them
The Olympian also spoke about her many
grandkids in December she says she will
be a grandmother to 20 generaiiy veiled
the name they picked out for her
spoiler alert it's not grandma they came
up with boom boom it kind of stuck it
was easy for him to say yeah a little
stormy yeah she boom boom boom boom here
in October Caitlyn celebrated her 70th
birthday surrounded by family at a
dinner thrown by daughter Kylie at
Malibu's Nobu restaurant her birthday
wish
in an interview with the website broadly
published last May Kaelin opened up
about missing her family saying quote I
have a lot of children but sometimes
just because of circumstances
maintaining a close relationship with
your kids is very tough they all have
lives they've all moved on
[Music]